creature he's obviously very hairy just
squatted down doesn't look like any
human
being he's taking a squat he's doing his
business he's just trying to do his
business out you know where else is he
going to go he's Bigfoot and this train
and now he's on camera which is pretty
embarrassing for him now I will say that
there's a community note on this post on
Twitter which says this this is located
in Silverton in Durango it's part of a
quite popular Bigfoot themed Expedition
Trailer company called Sasquatch
Expedition trailers the owner regularly
dresses up as Sasquatch that doesn't
prove anything to me just because this
was in a theme park apparently where
people dress up as Bigfoot that that to
me is not I don't find that to be
compelling evidence um against this
being the actual Bigfoot at all uh if
anything I think that only further
proves that it probably is the actual
Bigfoot because if you're the actual
Bigfoot where else would you go you
would probably go to a place like this
where you know that you'll be welcomed
and and accepted